let's talk a little bit more about Kevin
McCarthy
the circus-like atmosphere that has been
created uh by the Republican party uh is
is something to behold they're they're
they're
ushering in their power by him being
peppered with questions constantly
everywhere he goes setting up little
impromptu uh oppressors
being asked questions and he posted this
I guess in response to a question where
he has his little canned response in
order to create a sound bite
and he was so proud of this that he
tweeted this along with a video he
tweeted 100 Democrats just refused to
denounce socialism that's scary and it
explains a lot about why Congress has
been spending so much these last four
years
these last four years odd because Donald
Trump was president in part of that last
four years and in order for Congress to
spend any money again Republicans if
you're watching let me educate you on
how a bill is made
in order for an Appropriations Bill to
get to the president's desk for
Signature it must originate in the House
of Representatives and then it must make
its way through the Senate and then on
to the president's desk in this case
your dear leader Pumpkinhead Donald
Trump who signed it with his Sharpie
so you can't blame this on Democrats
these budgets were approved of
by a Republican president
and as far as socialism being scary
what would you have us do Kevin McCarthy
are we going to dispense with Social
Security
are we going to find another way to fund
our Public Schools
or our children millions of children
just to be left to fend for themselves
and educate themselves I mean that that
sounds like a republican Paradise
a a substandard education for children
so they're not able to think
and reason and make rational decisions
when they become adults
when it's time to vote for someone
here's Kevin McCarthy if I had to watch
it you've got to watch it
here's the video that was appended to
this particular tweet
a couple interesting things happen on
the floor right now you had almost if
you combine the number of Democrats who
voted no and voted present there's a
hundred Democrats that won't stand up
against socialism that's a real concern
to me in America today it's not just
that wasn't a college vote on a college
campus that was a vote in the U.S
Congress that 100 Democrats
couldn't say socialism was wrong that's
a scary point of view but you also
understand why we're in a spending
problem that they are when they were in
the majority that's why you understand
the challenges that we have here
so proud of that particular piece of
audio and video that he slapped his logo
on it it's watermarked as his own and he
tweeted it out proudly tweeted that out
what is scary
about socialism
do you think that uh Scandinavia is a is
a is a is a hellscape
they can't pay their bills
are people not free there
socialism if you listen to a republican
is
chaotic States like Venezuela
it's not the the prosperous
States all across the world who have
some semblance of socialism somewhere in
their in their system
much like the United States with Social
Security I mean sounds like Kevin
McCarthy wants some kind of uh dystopic
libertarian hellscape
where you're on your own
you get hurt
you you get disabled you lose your job
ah sorry you're on your own
you have children you want them educated
you're on your own
you retire and you want to live out your
golden years with some safety net
you should have invested more wisely
if you're poor you can't work you can't
find a job you're on your own
all of that
is answered by some level
of socialism
it's not a bad word that Republicans
would have you believe
it's just it's gross and and for in for
Kevin McCarthy's part of it it's just
dumb
because rational reasonable per people
across the country aren't falling for
this
the unfortunate thing is that millions
and millions and millions of Republicans
Fox News Watchers Newsmax Watchers oan
viewers they are falling for it they
think it's self-evident that socialism
is scary
come on
also come on I'd love to see you
subscribe to my YouTube channel to
search my name Jesse dollar more uh I am
also on social media at Dollar Moore
there a lot of dollar more action
related to me oddly enough and I also
host a podcast that doesn't have dollar
more in the title it's called I doubt it
it's co-hosted with me and my lovely
talented and scholarly co-host Brittany
page and we'd love to see you there
one of our sponsors today is zipx
nicotine toothpicks zipx brings you a
convenient alternative to smoking and
vaping and The Vape clouds the ashtrays
the thing in your lip that people can
see I've seen that around this is an
easier and less messy way to curb the
cravings and you can use zipx just about
anywhere zipx is available in six
flavors with two or three milligram
strength the nicotine and the flavor are
long lasting and zipix has helped
countless people kick the bad habits and
they are bad habits zipx toothpicks are
FDA registered their customer service is
second to none it is one of the most
cost effective Alternatives also check
out their B12 and caffeine toothpicks
see for yourself why so many people have
switched to zipx 2 picks you can only
get zipx online go to zipxtoothpix.com
and get 10 off with the code Pacman the
link is down below